hi there
i was asked to talk about learning kanji
in japanese kanji is
chinese characters
all right
i believe that
you can learn japanese without learning
the japanese character the chinese
characters the kanji but i recommend
learning them
because
japan japanese culture is part of this
sort of east asian culture
very heavily influenced by
china and chinese culture
to get into the chinese characters the
kanji is to really get into that east
asian culture and so forth so it's well
worth doing
is part of our history as human beings
you know
chinese characters
arabic script
cyrillic writing i mean all these
different things korean writing i like
exploring these things i also enjoy
reading in any language that i'm
learning if you want to read anything
serious
in japanese you have to have the
characters
i think reading is is tremendously
powerful for acquiring vocabulary so for
all of these reasons i think we should
learn the kanji now the kanji are
difficult
when i learned kanji i learned them in
chinese hanzo right chinese characters
i
didn't have the advantage of modern
technology so the first thousand i
deliberately wrote them out many many
times
i must admit that i don't have much need
to write kanji in fact i don't write in
the languages that i have learned
because it's so easy to use
the computer to write so we don't have
to write by hand so it's possible you
won't need to write the characters by
hand
but some form of engaging with how
they're written
i think helps us learn i don't know that
for sure and i'm very you know
interested in hearing
what other people do and there's lots of
different apps i checked out on you know
my iphone different apps for learning
characters and stuff
and what i ended up with what is what i
think is the best dictionary for
learning kanji and it's called jiso
jiso kanji
and we have added it to link
so
it just shows j-i-s-h-o which means
dictionary in japanese
um we've added it to link and if i were
learning
and i'm going to show you because i got
some software called loom which enables
me to show you what i'm doing on my
computer so i went through a
demonstration of using this gisho kanji
and then when i looked at my video i
realized that the loom doesn't capture a
pop-up
so therefore i will show you
some of the other things i do on our
website or that i would do if i were
learning japanese but i can't show you
the pop-up so i'll simply explain that
the dicho kanji pop-up comes up
uh since most words in japanese and
chinese are actually combinations of
kanji
so for example uh totsuzen suddenly
is totsu and zen totsuzen
and so jishukanji goes through each one
of these characters provides a lot of
information about the character
uh you know they sort of call it the
japanese style pronunciation the chinese
origin pronunciation
uh how important the character this is
difficulty level it shows you the stroke
order and it does it for each one of
these so that
if you are using link which i recommend
obviously that's what i like to use and
you come across characters every time
you come across it you can look it up in
this
dictionary and you can once again be
reminded of the range of meanings and
how it's used and its importance in
stroke and so on and if you keep on
doing that eventually they are going to
stick
uh you should also read about you know
some of the components of characters you
know the the the
water symbol the metal one or gold and
all these different things that reappear
as components of the characters and you
can go and find a book on that and you
should acquaint yourself
with these things even though initially
it's going to be
not so meaningful until you've been
exposed to a lot of characters it's like
grammar you
have to combine the exposure with some
degree of
explanation but put more emphasis on the
exposure rather than on the explanation
now the other thing that i would do
other than a lot of reading and frequent
lookups in this gisha kanji
is that i would avail myself of the
dictation function that we have at link
and i'll make a brief demonstration of
that with my screenshot
screencast here but that simply means
that you would set
your uh activities
to those are the review activities and
link you would set them to dictation and
not do the closed test or not do the
flash card just do the dictation
and if you are on a computer you have to
set your keyboard
to japanese if you are on an ipad or an
iphone
then within the link system it'll
automatically
go to a japanese keyboard if you have
that keyboard set up on your ipad or
portable device android whatever it
might be
uh and then you will hear the
text-to-speech pronunciation of a word
tortuzen and you will then be required
to type it
and then you will see the character pop
up
uh
and all of this is going to help you and
i should add that just the mere fact
that we have um
uh you know um
word processing softwares on our
computers whereby we type in a romanized
form of japanese and a number of
characters are suggested for us it's
another way of reviewing the characters
so technology makes it much easier
to learn
characters today you should still
get a book
which explains some of the components i
mean it's a matter of where your
interests lie
but make it a major project to learn the
characters
learn them as a part of your input
reading activities
and uh and
you know
bit by bit you know it seems like an
enormous tax task two thousand
characters but if you slice it off
salami style
going at it gradually gradually building
up forgetting relearning forgetting
relearning
you will eventually
become familiar
familiar enough with the characters
to read in my opinion and i think it's
something well worth doing and uh i will
show you briefly because i'm keen on
using this new software that i've got
how i would do that on our website at
link okay we'll go through to that part
of the presentation now bye for now
so using this loom software let's just
demonstrate how i would go about
working on my
kanji here at link
so first of all any blue words now bear
in mind i am not studying japanese so
this is not totally realistic but
obviously
i can save words i just click on them
like that
so i would be saving the words that had
um you know
characters
okay
so i have a bunch here that i've already
saved so
um
bear in mind by the way if you're not
aware of it that you can read you can
this is taken from
nhk easy news okay
and if it's difficult for you you can
choose to look at it sentence by
sentence
or you can look at it
page by page so bear in mind it's worth
exploring this sort of sentence
settings rather gear signal symbol here
because there are a number of things
that you can set
you can set you know what you want to
see in your home settings you can set
your reader settings
and you can also set your review
settings which i've set the dictation
because the dictation of
activity is kind of a good way to review
your kanji oh before we get there
i wanted to point out if you have a
kanji
and you want to look up the kanji you
would go to jishu kanji
and it would give you
the character how many strokes uh
meanings different meanings taught in
you know grade two jlpt level four it's
88 of the 2500 most used kanjis you've
got uh
other words that have this word in it
you got stroke order you got so much
information including translations into
other languages
now
if we were to choose
if we'll cut if you were to choose
something that
had two
okay a tai ho which is um
you know a double-barreled like a word
that consists of two
um
characters
again if you go to g-show kanji you'll
see them both so because the pop-up
doesn't show i can't show it to you but
bear in mind you can always add
dictionaries to the ones that you like
to consult
speaking of things that you can adjust
also in your reader settings we have a
thing called asian script and you can
adjust
as to whether you want to see hiragana
here or whether you want to see
romanized
uh a phonetic script of these words okay
so now to review them you click on this
to write it
and you listen to the text-to-speech
so you go like this
hawaii
now
ah i'm gonna choose
it's not there could be one or the other
i'm not afraid of getting it wrong let's
go to this mauri
correct okay there you go next
okay
again
i have uh tai ho so targo i'll go with
that
submit
so
uh you may not be able to see this it
might be off the screen but i have set
my keyboard to hiragana so that i'm able
to type phonetically and get these um
kanji to show up
uh on the ipad the keypad if you have
already got a japanese keypad it'll show
up automatically if you are in the
system so i just think in all the
languages that i've been learning with a
different script it's very helpful to do
this dictation function in order to
train yourself in this other script and
that's certainly the case with kanji but
ultimately it's a lot of reading a lot
of
exposure a lot of constant review that
will gradually enable you to get a
better and better sense of the kanji
and
that i'm gonna turn this off
okay an experiment it wasn't ideal
uh i noticed that when i was typing in
uh
in the dictation
uh
the part of the screen where um i chose
the uh correct uh kanji uh was not
visible so with this loom software some
things show and other things don't show
i think the big message is that like
everything in language learning you have
to explore on your own take on the
challenge of the kanji
you're going to do it sort of big
picture learning
reading listening reviewing and also
some deliberate specific effort to
understand the kanji to learn the kanji
possibly to to find some systems you may
want to do sort of some anki type
activity for your kanji or you may find
that it's enough just to encounter these
as you encounter them each time you
encounter them you look them up in the
gishwh kanji which is a a wonderful
dictionary and gradually just rely on
the fact that your brain will start to
get used to them so i hope that was
helpful bye for now
[Music]
you